rencontre avec une nouvelle élue de la
ville du mans marlène schiappa adjointe
en charge de l'égalité des droits et de
la lutte contre les discriminations elle
est également présidente de
l'association mamans travaillent
tournée vers les nouvelles technologies
marlène schiappa milite pour une
meilleure conciliation de la vie
professionnelle et de la vie familiale
elle n'hésite pas aussi à lancer le
débat pour une juste répartition des
rôles entre hommes et femmes
on essaye de faire progresser les choses
on va voir les ministères le parlement
européen le sénat l'assemblée nationale
les élus les grandes entreprises et on a
cette position assez confortable parce
qu'on est quelqu'un d'extérieur
l'association n'est pas un réseau n'est
pas un syndicat donc c'est facile pour
nous d'arriver et de dire ben voilà ce
qui va pas voilà ce que vous pourriez
améliorer on n'a rien à gagner là-dedans
à part faire avancer la cause finalement
classé sixième dans le top sont des
personnes qui font le web lui a valu
d'être remarqué par l'équipe de jean
claude boulard aujourd'hui elle est
nommée adjointe chargée de l'égalité et
de la lutte contre la discrimination à
la personne j'avais bien en faire en
sorte que l'égalité soit quelque chose
qui concerne tout le monde fédérer tout
le monde autour de cette valeur commune
du dénominateur commun qui est la ville
et la république et ne pas cloisonner
les personnes voilà c'est de
décloisonner un petit peu tout ce qui se
fait le mans c'est une ville pionnière
dans la lutte contre toutes les
discriminations
c'était une des premières villes adopté
à chartes lgbt c'est une ville très
engagé au niveau des droits des femmes
cet autodidacte de 32 ans se voit à
présent comme une médiatrice elle veut
impulser fédérer en tant qu'élu ça
suffit maintenant d'être sur le bord de
la piscine et de crier au jean alesi
nager comme ci comme ça en tant que
lobby et que maintenant il faut plonger
et faut nager nous aussi et même si au
début on nage pas très bien il faut
quand même essayé essayé d'aller dans la
direction dans laquelle on
aux autres d'aller voilà se mouiller
aussi finalement pour marlène schiappa
le savoir-faire sarthois ne suffit pas
il faut aussi le faire savoir
c'est ce qu'elle essaiera de mettre en
valeur
[Musique]